[Music]
my turn with more - reaction or opening
monologue civil and criminal defense
attorney David shown former US attorney
for the District of Columbia Jodi
Jennifer Joe are you opening monologue
you also heard about follow the money
but let me let me go to the issue of
sessions clearly the president feels
betrayed that sessions recused himself
didn't give him a heads up that he was
going to do this which is a big deal
and clearly sessions based on his
comments today doesn't like the
president if the president fires him
though he's in a box
everybody's gonna I can hear it out
Saturday night massacre analogies all
over the place so the president's in a
spot he doesn't have an attorney general
never had an attorney general the
biggest abuse of power case nothing
happens on one side but it only happens
about taxicab medallions and you know
bank loan applications right well the
President of the United States was and
is entitled to a fully engaged Attorney
General he has never had that Jeff
Sessions made a terrible mistake
besides accepting the job knowing he
would have to recuse himself in the
single most important matter as soon as
he became Attorney General Jeff Sessions
sort of had a major speech indicating
what he thought about the way the
Hillary Clinton case was handled and say
that he was going to appoint a special
counsel to investigate that case and to
investigate the conduct of the people at
senior levels of the FBI and the
Department of Justice he should do it he
should do it today and here's here's the
problem Jeff Sessions has no command
presence he doesn't understand the job
that he has he never has it is very
regrettable but at after the next
election Jeff should give the president
the courtesy of a resignation because
here's why
Sean Jeff Sessions has told people that
he doesn't believe that people at the
Department of Justice are capable of the
kinds of things that they're being
accused of calmly simply refuses age we
join Sean he is blind Jeff session is
blind and he's surrounded by Rod
Rosenstein who agrees with him and an
FBI director
Chris way who is an empty suit who by
the way has never said a nasty word
about all of the people that were the
head of the FBI before him he is so out
of his league as FBI director and so
what is the president presented with
three people who don't know how to do
their jobs sessions it becomes as I said
what he had F sessions has to be a man
and resign after then after the election
listen the president has the article to
authority to do exactly that this is a
person who serves at his will in the
political fallout right and that's he's
being counseled on the political fallout
undoubtedly but this president has to
stop being reactive and concerned about
those things once and for all he was
elected to be a man of action he was
elected to serve his constituency which
is at least half of the country he needs
action in this position see yes you see
where we are now I mean these people
have wanted to impeach him we saw what
they tried to do to prevent him from
winning for anyone anyway and then they
still go on after they never stopped
going after him the election in the
minds of the deep State never stops but
that's just the point they're going to
continue that no matter what he does or
if he does nothing that's an effort to
overturn the election results through
otherwise we do it through the election
process
exactly they can't go through the ballot
box oh look Joe I'm a capitalist I don't
care that people make money and frankly
if you have you or the FBI director that
experience is worth money in the in the
private sector I want to be very clear I
don't know if anything nefarious has
gone on why did I not know until I read
this book 36 million and we do call for
the five years because James Comey and
Bob Muller and people like Chris Rea do
one thing very well they hide their bad
faults and Comey and Muller are so close
they're like they came out of the same
womb this is so outrageous about the
conflicts of interest that exists with
Muller he never should have been
appointed special counsel Rosen Stein
knew that he knew about all those
conflicts and yet he did it anyway did
it
the guy hired he worked for Lockheed
Martin commis the FBI director all those
would agree with you more
couldn't agree with you more this these
are politically corrupt people the
conflicts are outrageous and as I said
after the next election
Jeff sessions should resign and make way
for a real Attorney General who needed
special counsel and this is the old
dancing patterns of the way of these
folks out of office supporting each
other that's why you heard so many
former officials screaming when Brennan
had his security clearance taken away
where clearly it had to be taken away
it's an old boys network and that's what
MIT president Trump threatens all right
thank you both